hello sir congratulations I mean there
he is come on how does it feel now that
it's in your hands on cloud nine I bet
yes the Hollywood dream come true right
yeah yeah so you sing during your
acceptance speech
there was only one wish on my mind
so was Raja maulis and my families what
did you sing during the acceptance the
top of the world okay yeah of course of
course it's like being on the top of the
world okay now did you get to meet
anyone while you were there at the
Oscars tonight pardon me did you meet
anyone that you were excited to at the
Oscars tonight I didn't have time yeah
you were busy I'm sitting with my wife
all the time and I enjoying the show of
course and they just came out in this
yeah so where are you gonna put Oscar
pardon me where are you gonna put Oscar
when you get home uh
in my music room yeah yeah because
that's that's where everything happens I
love it what do you think your home
country is thinking right now
yeah they are they're celebrating I bet
yeah crackers everywhere
foreign